crenn kiev annonce une contre offensive
dans le sud ce lundi l'armée veut
récupérer la ville de carson villes
contrôlées par les russes lors des
premiers jours de la guerre bonjour
baptiste falvo aux bons les autorités
locales assurent que les ukrainiens ont
davantage sur le front sud oui alors ce
front sud on va d'ailleurs le voir sur
la carte et cette ville de carson vous
venez de le dire premières grandes
villes conquises par l'armée ukrainienne
c'était le 2 mars dernier elle se situe
ici voilà sur le fleuve nieppe que vous
voyez ici alors il faut être très
prudent d'abord sur les annonces de
l'armée ukrainienne il faut savoir que
cette reconquête de la ville de rennes
sonne c'est un serpent de mer ça fait
des semaines qu'on entend parler d'une
d'une reprise de terrain à venir dans
cette donc près de cette ville de renson
et notamment dans l'oblast de personnes
qui est la région qui inclurait lawson
et jusqu'ici pour l'instant ce sont
plusieurs dizaines de villages qui ont
été reconquis mais n'est rien vraiment
de très solides la contre offensive
actuelle cette fois à l'air plus étayée
d'abord parce que ces dernières semaines
l'armée ukrainienne a vu arriver des
systèmes d'armement beaucoup plus
sophistiqué beaucoup plus précis
notamment d'armements américains on
pense au fameux lance-roquettes haye
mars et puis ça fait suite à des
semaines de travail de sape de cette
armée ukrainienne contre des
infrastructures stratégiques pour les
russes dans cette région de renson des
dépôts de munitions mais également des
ponts et en particulier trois ponts qui
traversent le fleuve dniepr ici et qui
gênent considérablement
le ravitaillement des troupes russes qui
se situe vous le voyez ici c'est à dire
sur la rive droite
on peut dire la rive ouest du nil est
pris et 7 cette zone là côté russe
serait aujourd'hui presque totalement
isolé et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas un
hasard si visiblement les ukrainiens
attaque d'abord par cette partie nord
partie ouest rive droite on va y arriver
du fleuve dniepr c'est très important
donc pour pour perturber les russes mais
encore une fois il faut vraiment être
très prudente on a eu des effets
d'annoncé qu'il faut pas oublier que
l'armée ukrainienne est avant tout une
armée défensive et maintenant ça va être
on va l'avoir à l'épreuve pouvoir
reconquérir comme ça massivement des
territoires c'était pas si facile
l'armée écrit